[Music]
i was doing the show the view and as you
may or may not know whoopi goldberg is
one of the posts of the show and i
pitched the producers the idea of doing
my whoopi goldberg impression on the
show and i was like it might be she
might be feel weird about it or i never
met her so you know she's a big star you
never might just be like oh pick whoop
let him do
[Laughter]
i it see what the big whoopee is
um there's a knock at the door i
answered it and it was whoopi herself
and she said
yeah i think you should use these and
she gave me her glasses
her like purple kind of like john lennon
round glasses and uh
she said like this is gonna help and she
like she helped me out with it she gave
me the glasses to wear do you know i've
known who whoopi goldberg is my entire
life i've never even noticed that she
has unique glasses or anything what ever
oh really so to me a whoopi goldenberg
impression without the glasses is the
same thing as the goldberg impression
with the glasses that's funny it's not
like doing uh groucho marks without a
mustache right then you'd be chico
that's true you know they look very
similar these brothers are brothers no i
know but like really similar so does
heartbone i know all three of them yeah
but zeppo is a little more handsome
handsome anyway we're off on a tantrum
okay well that's the show speaking of
tangents let's get ready for the show
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening to life is short i'm
your tangent prone host justin long life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my uh more distinct
yes i was gonna say
streamlined but sustained is better it's
more succinct
um
and why are we talking about the marx
brothers and whoopi goldberg we
shouldn't have been talking about the
marx brothers that was my fault that was
me not being succinct yeah weird that's
uncharacteristic of me yeah
uh it's not a characteristic bobby
goldberg
she was so cool about it it's been a
while since i've done it so i don't want
to well she's cool about most things
when she said she is [ __ ] cool you
know what's cool about she takes her
time with her words
and it's all very like she's very
deliberate but she's a great just great
voice beautiful voice which i don't have
so i'm it's not a great impression but
uh she was so cool to me and we had so
much fun on the show i fun bantering
with her do you know what movie i like
uh of whoopi goldbergs jumping jack
flash love it yeah well you know what
another movie i like at first
ghost i do love ghost you know i saw it
recently it it's hard to watch ghost and
not get uh teary a little emo that's
incredible and demi moore to me i still
don't know i think it's to me uh anyway
i was gonna say humble braggy thing i've
met her and i don't know how to say it i
don't know say it then to me uh why were
we talking about ghost because
our guest today is at not only ghosts
the movie but um whoopi played a medium
in that movie odama brown yeah it's a
fun name to say it is a fun name she
rolls off the tongue otta mae brown what
a great name uh who wrote that movie i
don't know it's so good [ __ ] and don't
get me started on patrick swayze swayze
yeah i won't i won't because we don't
have time for it but today our guest is
a non-fictional medium her name is
teresa caputo better known as the long
island medium yes the world knows her as
the long island medium which is a very
popular show yes but maybe caputo's some
caputos are listening and they know her
as uh teresa or mom theresa yeah yeah uh
she is the long island medium which is
was a show on
tlc for a number of years i think nine
years maybe i think it's still on now uh
i don't know but i'm sure you can find
it on a streamer yeah you can stream it
yeah and she is as
you're about to hear a very
down-to-earth
normal i would say
person who just so happens to have these
uh extraordinary abilities of seeing and
communicating with dead people it's like
haley chill osman in the sixth sense
which we talk about she's like a
grown-up real-life female version of
haley yeah in fact she said we should
save this but she said when she saw that
movie that that was like an eye-opening
experience it was it was enlightening
for her like oh my god i i'm not alone
that's how much you could identify with
that character
anyway so you be the judge of it
fascinates me i mean regardless of
whether or not you believe in it um
it's just i god is it fascinating the
whole idea of an afterlife and somebody
here on earth who might be able to
communicate with them it is just
doesn't it
and it is very interesting and
to test her powers we wanted to give her
a bit of a challenge and since justin is
pretty easily google-able
uh we didn't want her to do a reading on
him and because i was too scared to do
it
um really my girlfriend and justin's
friend maggie
had a reading done yes we've talked
about maggie before on the show but uh
this is probably the definitely the most
you're gonna hear from maggie so you'll
hear that a little bit later in the
interview just to hear an example of
what teresa does how she works and of
course it was over zoom
so she claims that it didn't limit her
abilities
we're going to talk to maggie as well at
the end of the show just to get her
thoughts on how it went and right now
we're going to get theresa's thoughts on
life and the afterlife and all things in
between
coming up next
my interview with teresa caputo the long
island medium
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
how are you theresa i'm great i'm great
where are you exactly i'm at home in
hicksville long island hicksville okay
yeah i still live right next door to my
parents what did they think of your
abilities how old were you in these
began well for me
you have to realize i've always been
sensing and feeling things since the age
of four i can remember seeing a woman
standing at the end of my bed and uh
seeing shadows and people speak to me in
a room and
i come from a very strong faith family
and a very spiritual family so was it a
christian like christian based catholic
roman catholic okay yeah but i always
say i tell people that because they they
want to know like do you have a faith do
you believe in god and i am a practicing
catholic and that's what i struggled
with with my gift because i was like
okay god has blessed me with this gift
what am i supposed to do with this right
you know i don't know any different
nobody ever made a big deal about the
things that i would say well one of the
biggest stories of my family was i was
16
and my dad's my nanny had just passed
away and we were at her house and i was
standing there like talking to the
drapes and my cousin nick came over to
me and he's like cuz what are you doing
and i'm like oh i'm talking to nanny and
he's like no you're talking to the
drapes you're a weirdo and he walked
away from me oh my god he's like nanny
is dead we just came from her funeral
and what does he think of that story now
does he is it somebody like that who was
skeptical at the time how do they feel
about it now oh yeah they're like oh my
god she's always been doing this stuff
like it's crazy you know when i went
through a really long um
most people not everyone really knows my
story um
you know of how i suffer from anxieties
because of my gift because i am empathic
because that's the way i communicate is
through feeling
um and you must take on a lot of
people's yes feelings yeah
and you know i would always say i don't
know how this works my mind just gets
clear and then
i have no personal thoughts feelings or
emotions it becomes
that of the soul and
i actually um
did this on dr oz uh live with uh dr
eamon he's a brain
expert and he he read my brain as i was
reading somebody oh yeah i've heard
about i heard about this yes yeah and
he's like theresa literally when you
were reading your brain like flatlined
like you had no activity but you were
speaking and he said that i was able to
access a part of the brain that we
typically don't on an everyday basis
right so then do you chalk it up to if
you were to like
clinically analyze your gift your
abilities do you chalk it up to
receptive you're open in a way that most
people aren't i chalk it up too and i
don't mean to quote lady gaga but i was
born this way
i always felt like there was something
missing deep within my soul
and i always felt i would say to my mom
at the age of five and seven i feel
different i feel like i don't belong
here and my mom would literally say to
me you're not adopted so there's no
reason why you should feel that way and
until i embraced my gift and here i was
well in well i was in my 30s i married
two beautiful children still having my
grandparents i only lost my grandparents
recently
my parents are still alive so i have all
of these blessings in my life and you
felt incomplete right but when i
embraced my gift
is when i felt complete oh interesting
and how exactly what form did that take
theresa was was it as simple as
telling people you know like kind of
coming out of the closet
yes
absolutely it was a part you know
because yeah you just i mean my poor
kids going to school they're in school
and everyone's like oh what does your
mom do they're like kids like oh my
mom's a nurse my mom's a teacher and
there's my kids oh my dad is an italian
importer and my mom speaks to dead
people
you know
wow yeah so what do they make of it i
mean what was that journey like just
through their eyes honestly they don't
know any different yeah right what got i
guess uh
odd for them was then people making a
big deal about what i did they're like
what's the big deal you know they would
just see people coming to the house one
way
and leaving the house completely
different almost like reformed i
struggled with my gift for over five
years once i found out
what it was what was happening to me and
what i had the ability to do because i
believe we all have that ability to
connect with our own departed loved ones
i'm just able to sense everyone else's
loved ones well i want i want to talk
about how you went about embracing it
and what steps you took but but even
before that i'm curious about this
moment that you had when you were four
what was
do you remember that transformative
moment you said it was a lady at the
foot of your bed i i always remember uh
a woman at the foot of my bed and i used
to have these reoccurring nightmares um
of a man chanting they were coming for
me they were coming for me and this
woman would always be standing at the
foot of my bed and it was almost like
she was protecting me and i was well
into my 30s and i saw a picture i was at
my grandmother's house and i'm like
graham who was this woman in this
picture and she's like that's my mom
and i'm like shut up i'm like that is
the woman that has been sitting at the
end of my bed since i'm four why wait
this was your mom this was your
grandmother's mom
yes
wow this was my mom's grandmother it was
incredible it was like when i first if
you want to say came out about my gift
there's something chilling about just
hearing you say that but it at the time
was it comforting or was it more scary
at the time it was definitely scary my
mom i would wake up with blood curdling
screams like literally my mom would say
she would come into the room and she'd
be like expecting someone like murdering
me like these night terrors i mean it's
so bad that one night i convinced my
father and my brother to go up on the
roof at three o'clock in the morning
because there was a a man looking in my
window but then the the figure of the
woman with that kind of like molly would
that calm you and and
did you feel protected by her
at that time yes so what was happening
was i was sensing other souls and other
things so she was there to protect me
so it all didn't come together until
like i said in my 30s i had gone to a
spiritual awareness class where i was
safely able to explore my gifts so i
would come into this class
and for me it was my way of saying okay
this is my safe place where i can
explore the gift and i'm like okay well
who's going to want to come and see
medium like i could not understand why
god would bless me with this gift but
surely you knew that that was uh
vocation i mean like people go to
mediums like you saw ghost
yeah but you're talk listen
i'm no youngster
i'm talking over 30 something years ago
so literally ghost
actually sixth sense was a really good
description of me as a child like how it
was and i would say thanks to my mom and
my mom never really made a big deal
about anything um you know and even
people in my family you know we all have
gifts
once you embraced it and you started
using it to help people i'm sure it
changed did it get better did it get
easier to deal with
absolutely so in the beginning i used to
see things i would see
figures of people and when you say
figures were you described that were you
able to make out features of their faces
could you
like make a police sketch of them i
could back then so what would happen was
people i would sometimes i would before
someone would come for a session when i
would prepare for the reading yeah i
would start to sense and feel things
before the session
so i'd be brushing my teeth look up in
the mirror and then all of a sudden
there'll be a man standing behind me and
be like and then he'll go away
oh my god the best did they seem
sinister ever did they ever seem like no
no it was just for like a split second
just for that split second so the best
story that i have is the last time this
ever happened was i was getting ready i
was at the sink i was cleaning up before
someone came looked up there was a young
man standing at the window
and he had on he looked like the brawny
paper towel guy oh and yeah okay
so the young lady comes and
i start seeing the whole image again of
this man at the window for that split
second oh wow oh my god she goes that
was my brother she says that was my
brother she says that is we used to
tease him and say that he looked like
the brawny paper towel oh my god crazy
and that's the thing like you have to
understand something about me justin i'm
the first one to say that what i do is
absolutely crazy yeah you don't seem in
any way i never really spent time
talking to a medium and but my the
prejudice about them
preconceived notion would have been that
they were
you know like oda may like a little
wacky yup and listen but it's like
anything in any occupation can i say
that like there's good and bad in
everything right sure so
you know that yeah that ying and the
yang that's what makes the world go
around right and you just seem so kind
of reasonable and you seem connected to
you seem present and not at all
absolutely because listen yeah i
you asked me this earlier uh like when
did this turning point happen for you
yeah yeah and it was 9 11.
because i was struggling with my gift
and i i couldn't understand and
um
the
what happened was is
i said to to god i said i'm putting my
gift in your hands
if this is what i'm meant to do and if
this is my journey here in the physical
world then i want to help people
um and what i realized was that
unfortunately after we lose a loved one
we're left with burdens and guilts maybe
no answers
and all of these negative emotions do
not give us the ability to heal so that
is what i use my gift for is for healing
purposes to help people heal yeah and to
move forward with their life with some
sort of happiness and joy and here i am
you know i so after 9 11 i i opened uh
my gift and threw
a business card i didn't even have a
website i had nothing i i had a business
card and a phone number and um
and here i am wow yeah it's funny you
it's interesting you say that teresa
because i i would imagine if i were to
die
and i had a life in another realm
i would want the first thing i would
want to do
would be to somehow
get word to my family that i was okay
and i would want to i would not want
them to spend the rest of their life in
this physical world
burdened by as you say guilt or any kind
of
sadness i mean i'd like them to be a
little sad it'd be crazy if they were
like you know
throwing parties the next day you know a
morning period uh but i wouldn't want it
to ruin their lives i would want them to
be able to
that's the thing everyone is different
you know um and i i wrote about that in
my last book good grief um that
everyone is different we have we're
going to go through different stages of
healing we might go through the in that
order or we might never ever ever feel
those emotions
seeing a medium isn't for everyone you
know um is it you know is it the woman
that you know loses her husband after
being married for 65 years
uh is it the parents that lose a child
tragically what does that refer to
they're being good grief so there's good
in grieving we can find goodness and
grieving that there is a good way to
grieve and i i always try to tell people
look we're gonna grieve the loss of our
loved ones for the rest of our lives
here in the physical world but the
healing process is something completely
different and a lot of times people
don't realize like i love people that'll
say that they don't understand what i do
which is fine and they'll go i don't see
anything i don't
feel my loved ones around me and then
all of a sudden spirit will say things
and they're like oh my god yes that has
happened i'm like that's them and you
know and that's the thing with spirit
like i get that this is hard to
understand what i do
so and there are common things that
might happen you know throughout
someone's session because there are
going to be common ways people die
common burdens and guilts that we carry
so with every healing message that
spirit has me deliver they have to give
me something completely unique something
there is no way
anyone would know about totally
ungoogleable exactly these and then
they're little things they could be of
something that happened years ago to
remind you of the happy times they might
talk about something that happened since
since they died to validate that their
soul is with you and they're not missing
out the favorite thing that i love what
spirit does is they communicate with
their personality
because i wouldn't know that personality
and i always say whether someone died
suddenly or maybe you watched your loved
ones suffer for years and their disease
took away their personality how amazing
is it for spirit to show their
personality to validate that from the
moment the soul leaves the physical body
they leave behind every disability
ailment negativity they don't take it
with them on the other side what what is
that like to see
the how a message like that is received
like let's say it's from somebody who
had declined
uh in a very tragic way and and you're
delivering this message that to you may
seem totally benign and then you see the
way it's received and the emotion
what is that like to be the deliverer of
that kind of thing it's
the most amazing feeling but more
importantly a validation that
this is what i'm supposed to do here in
the physical world because
to have someone come
and i can feel their pain their sorrow
you have to also understand during a
reading spirit brings us through this
emotional rollercoaster they they give
us this ability to feel
uh and acknowledge the pain the sorrow
the loss and the grief and then in the
next breath they're giving us the gift
of laughter and to watch someone smile
and it just happened uh the other day
and it's happened numerous times i i had
read a woman that um unfortunately lost
her son to suicide
and
she was she was smiling at the end of
the reading and he said he literally
said to me teresa thank you for giving
my mom the gift of laughter again
and i said to him jaden i go you did it
yourself you did it i'm just i'm just
delivering the message you know wow did
that spirit feel guilt did they have
guilt about you know
creating so much sorrow for the mom
uh no it wasn't guilt he was sorry for
what it had brought her uh but he
explained to her like what had happened
what had led up to it and
you know and was that comfort did that
seem comfortable
it it changed her life the grief is
still there she'll feel that emptiness
but at least she has some type of peace
something to say okay he knows of all
these things that we're doing in memory
of him he's there he sees us and if he
wasn't okay he would not be able to
acknowledge these things i say to people
too if spirit wasn't in a good place
it's almost like human beings negative
people talk about negative things right
positive people talk about positive
things even though i treat spirit like
my children and i say if you have
nothing nice to say don't say anything
at all
oh really what's an example of something
negative maybe that a spirit did
happen to
blurt out or
express to you would be like if uh say a
father figure or someone um was
apologizing uh for the way that they
treated someone
um those those are hard messages
sometimes people don't want to hear from
that person but the soul because i
always say to people a reading the
information you receive is what you need
not what you want
right right and sometimes we don't
realize what we need until after we
uh experience something like this right
right yeah does it ever become like
dramatic to the point where the person
doesn't want to hear anymore from from
somebody
no that has happened twice
once the first time that ever happened
to me was probably about
14 years ago a man came to my home and
he sat palms folded i said to him i said
look i said i i don't know if this is
for you
and he said no no he says i'm very
interested to hear what you have to say
i said okay i said but i feel like i'm
being blocked and he seemed very nice i
mean he didn't you know but i think
there was almost it was so much sorrow
and and burden carried to the departure
right and so i said to spirit i said
look i'm not going to sit here and go
all day back and forth with an hour i
said you need to step forward and really
tell me what it is that he needs to hear
because sometimes spirit goes slowly
into you know messages and his wife came
forward and his wife can be long-winded
yeah
yeah
um she started saying some things and uh
he looked at me with tears in his eyes
and he said
theresa you're right he says uh this
isn't for me i'm not ready wow wow and
uh he said i i thank you uh for your
time and for your insight
and any less wow and it was the woman it
was his wife his wife he was so broken
and he felt that he didn't do enough for
his wife and oh my god yeah and she was
trying to comfort him but he was just so
broken from it he wasn't receptive to
yeah and then there was one of the time
i was doing uh a live show uh i was
doing an arena so i think there was
about five thousand people and i was all
the way up in the because when i do like
a live show like you get into the
audience right in there i want to be
right in front of the person
yeah and there was a gentleman
his son had died and uh he was sobbing
and you know you're standing up in front
of five thousand people on a big screen
and he dropped the mic and walked out he
couldn't handle it holy [ __ ] yeah but
there's there was healing there you know
oh yeah yeah and i get it and i say to
people listen this isn't for everyone
seeing a medium isn't for everyone some
people
uh you know i read a woman recently and
she she was at peace with her dad's
passing like she had no burdens or
anything and she goes i just wanted to
make sure that he was okay that was it
yeah
you know and then other people come and
they're so broken do people ever come
theresa and you're it's just like you're
not seeing anything i mean that must
happen no
wow no wow
it's also different if someone doesn't
acknowledge anything yeah you know i
also i can also feel if i'm delivering a
message and i'm like hmm i don't know
i'll say i don't know if this is right
but
but i i you know i learned a long time
ago i this is who i am
i have an amazing and beautiful gift i
will never try to prove or defend my
gift to anybody because that must become
exhausting but that must be turned into
like 90 of what you do but that's not
the point of what i do no yeah yeah you
know what i mean like i i don't i and i
don't mean to be rude i start off all my
speeches i don't care if you believe in
what i do right right all i care about
is that you know that there truly is
more to life than just here in the
physical world but more importantly that
your loved ones are with you you have
not lost that soul bond they are still
there communicating with you giving you
signs and symbols that's it you said you
were brought up catholic you're still
catholic you you have a very strong
faith and belief system
how has that altered how is that
strengthened i would imagine it
strengthened your beliefs it really has
you know i mean growing up i mean who
wasn't afraid to die right i'm not
afraid to die look i don't want to die
but let's face it we're all going to die
at some point but i'm not afraid this is
probably an obvious answer but what was
it about 9 11 was it something was it
just the amount of death that
the amount of tragedy that it caused
absolutely prompted that it's kind of
just in like this pandemic you know uh
where people are passing and there's no
closure i
choose not to use the word closure
because i feel closure is so final
it implies an ending yeah yeah and and
really with uh
in death the only thing that has ended
is that physical connection that
physical bond but not the soul bond
and like with 9 11
people perished and there was nothing
left of them they could not be found
and this pandemic people are dying alone
people weren't able to see their loved
ones and
you know that's you know really hard as
well they're not even able to
celebrate or honor their loved ones in a
way and the thing that i know that my
gift will be able to bring people some
type of comfort and peace is that
spirit will say like one of my symbols
is spirit will step forward in a
three-piece suit and spin around and
come out in jeans and a t-shirt
that's my civil photo where they want to
thank someone for the way that they
chose to lay them to rest
and then they'll have me go on to say
what we do with the physical body they
don't care they're not trying to sound
cold or rude but it's for us
so they don't want us because you know
the term that we use oh they must be
turning in their grave did you see what
you laid your mother out in
yeah i've heard some elvis presley
renditions that have come to that same
yeah
um yeah oh that's funny so they're like
yeah hey look thanks for taking care of
my body but i don't really care that's
how i would think i would be as it goes
because we're not a part of it our body
it's like it's i use the the the
description of dry ice like you know how
dry ice is and it just like vaporizes
yeah that's what our soul is like life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wundery app
[Music]
hello hello again
we'll meet again
[Music]
you have a family 9 11 happens you have
this epiphany and you're you're
compelled to use your gift how do you
then become a professional medium how do
you then go to get to the point where
you're at now um it was a it was a long
journey i literally called up my mom and
i said uh i talked to dead people you
tell dad and i hung up the phone
yeah but yeah
she's like wait a minute are you gay
[Applause]
um
but but
surely she must have she sounds like
somebody who would be open to that
completely i i would not be where i am
without my mom
you know um and my grandmother uh she
was also very spiritual you know
and um and has had spiritual experiences
so
not to the level of what i did things
but um
so they believe you fully they they when
you absolutely yeah a thousand percent
uh comforting to them you're
communicating with their mothers and
they're yeah so what happened was i just
started uh you know uh it was all
through word of mouth you know uh people
coming for readings and then um courtney
mullen and victoria woods um
uh courtney is my manager and uh
victoria works on my team now
courtney came to unfortunately they lost
their dad
and they had come for a reading
and it changed their life and they were
like everyone should have this
opportunity
this gift after losing a loved one and
courtney was in is involved in
television so she came to me and said oh
you want to you know do a television
show i'm like yeah all right you know i
never i didn't think anything of it you
know and um
yeah was that ever anything you aspired
to do like did you even did you like act
in high school were you ever into show
but no no okay
were you did you have reservations about
it like i i don't want to be known cause
like you said you know already it's
weird that your kids go to school and
they're like yeah mommy talks to dead
people so now you're going now you're
dealing with a whole other
element of not only do you have this
ability and this kind of like strange to
understand thing for people but also now
potentially you could be famous so
you're dealing with that
did you ever
hesitate at all to pursue that well the
interesting thing justin is because i
never thought for one hot second that i
would be quote-unquote famous i still
don't think i'm famous when people say
like oh oh i love it i'm like you know
my show you've seen my show like you
know who i am yeah i i i and whether
people really understand this or not i
literally say all the time i'm just
theresa caputo i'm from hicksville new
york and i talk to deaf people
yeah you know
i gotta say i there's nothing
performative or presentational about you
you just seem so kind of like
down to earth and like you you really do
seem like theresa caputo from hicksville
long island like that doesn't
that's it
it makes me wonder if you had just like
performing reservations or
you know like being in front of 5 000
people with a little headset and like
justin i have a diarrhea attack every
time i'm about to hit that stage like i
am so nervous wow okay but but before
you go on the stage before i go yeah i
literally don't have diarrhea but
but i was hoping theresa actually that i
i think they mentioned this to you and
totally understandable if if it's not
something
you can do even is um
my brother's girlfriend is maggie that's
uh i i live with maggie and
maggie's had dealt with quite a i'll
just say it i mean she's had a lot of
loss in her life and so i've been
already writing i've read it i've been
writing mom dad you have to understand
oh i feel things differently you know um
i was already feeling so if you want to
bring her in i could because i don't
want to start saying things and then
yeah theresa i would love that hold on
one second let me grab her thank you hi
theresa hi hi how are you
hi good teresa thank you for agreeing to
oh listen
i always say i have such an amazing and
beautiful gift and if someone needs
uh the gift of healing then i'm willing
to do that are you familiar with how i
work on how i feel and
see spirits yes okay yes okay so i have
seen your show before oh perfect
so um what happens is i feel an
emotional bond that you shared with
someone here in the physical world or
the way that you knew them here then
they typically make me feel the way that
they departed okay
okay why they do that is to validate
that their souls are at peace but more
importantly that they are still with you
wow okay okay so as i was talking to
justin
and i was like dude i always just doodle
and write
i felt that there was uh a father figure
present now if it's not your dad it
could be your grandfather it could be an
uncle somebody that was like a father to
you justin it could also be for you um
okay
and then there was also a mother figure
but more importantly than that because i
am going to say this there's about six
souls that are there that that are there
right now um someone did labor my
breathing so that's my symbol for that
they died from something of the heart
lungs or breasts something with the
breath or they filled up with the fluid
because i just felt like i felt like i
was drowning
yes
do you understand that i do
yes my mother
passed from lung cancer okay so know
that this is her way of saying to you
that she does not want you to remember
her struggling to breathe do you
understand that yes okay because what
she did is she laid me in a bed now when
i describe something to you
you need to place it on how it fits in
your life okay
she laid me in a bed she held my hand
and she had me watch her take three deep
breaths and then i heard something
and then she passed
that's my symbol for if somebody either
witnessed the passing or more
importantly validating that they did not
suffer to their death wow do you
understand that yes okay yes did you sit
with your mom's physical body after she
departed i did not okay so um two things
because we i'm going to go back to the
holding of the hands
that's my symbol for that nothing was
left unsaid so sometimes that'll be a
validation for someone that they did do
that sometimes it is for someone that
did not and they might um
have a regret or feel bad about not
being able to quote unquote say goodbye
or not be there
yes
so i certainly so know that it's her way
of saying she does not want you to feel
that way
nothing was left unsaid did you just say
something to her now like i love you mom
or i miss you i just thought about her
and that moment and that guilt perfect
because she just said i love you too
is your mom gone for some time yes
because she goes theresa she goes look
how big matt's got look how big she is
she's so beautiful
so
that's my symbol for when someone loses
someone and we feel that they might have
missed out on a lot of their life yes
yes i was um
just turning 16. i was young 1997. so
know that is your mom's way of saying
that she has not missed out wow do you
um did you write something about your
mom because she showed me a yellow piece
of paper and wrote my hero on the top of
it that's my symbol for where somebody
wrote something in honor and or in
memory of their departed loved one i
think i wrote about her in my college
as a writing piece for college injury
and i mean i've certainly written
journals about her and so know that
personal know that she knows look
i know that might sound odd but that's
something that i would not know about
that
yeah validating that she wants to thank
you for the amazing and beautiful
tribute that you gave her and again
don't take things for granted i didn't
go to college
yeah
they don't teach this [ __ ] in school
i always tell people i went to uh dks
university don't know [ __ ]
yeah
that sounds like an actual school yeah
it's my school
i'm still going there yeah i
i teach there yeah
i'm the dean of
admissions
your mom showed me a gardenia uh
gardenias when spirit shows me gardenias
it's my symbol for it could be favorite
flower or more importantly you're
smelling things that remind you of your
mom and there's no reason why you should
be smelling it could be a perfume
sometimes i'll smell french toast and no
one's cooking it because it was
something that my grandmother always
made me
but you know what's really interesting
when you said gardenia and it reminded
me of flowers and something that
sort of symbolized her and it was part
of the funeral and something that i
linked to her is an iris a flower and
it's just bloomed a yellow iris in her
garden perfect and so when i saw that to
even today i saw it and i've been taking
pictures of it it's
beautiful and it just reminds me of her
perfect but when things happen like that
know that your mom's soul is with you at
that exact moment look it's very easy
it's not easy for me to say these things
to you or we might think that it's
common but those are the little details
that nobody else would know right things
that you do
things that you've done it validates
that she has been with you throughout
this she also tells me
there also has to be something else um
somebody passed from something of the
throat
or they were not able to communicate in
the end because
they're restricting my throat
yeah um i do know um my grandfather um
had something similar to that where he
was choking um
fluids um i wasn't there
it's possible other members of my family
so just know that they're all together
on the other side
um do you know someone that died
tragically yes
because i'm having i'm starting to taste
blood and that's my symbol for when
someone died tragically
i can feel like a little bit of um where
uh i don't know if you're afraid if
they're not going to come through or
step forward or what they might say or
not say does that make sense
yeah i am i had um both my father and my
brother passed tragically separately in
accidents
yes yes cause i got the blow to the
chest
and then um
see this is what happens they bring me
through the departure because they don't
want you to feel the suffering
what they stand together they don't
separate
so that means that it comes uh
um
their
information is coming from the both of
them but you have to place it separately
your your brother
i feel takes responsibility for his
departure
now when a soul takes responsibility
what that means is that
they spirit does not want us to feel
that we could have prevented or done
anything
to prevent the passing
wow
they take responsibility for because it
doesn't mean that they intentionally
take their own life what it means is
that they take responsibility for their
actions or sometimes non-actions that
cause or a tribute to their passing
interesting did you have a dream of your
brother
i do perfect yes i don't dream of my
loved ones that have died but your
brother did was he showed me him
standing this is just my symbol
him standing at the end of your bed you
seeing him vividly and he is
fine smiling healthy right
yeah that was his soul's way of coming
to you to let you know that he was okay
because that's how he wants you to
remember him
that i do dream often oh that's so
lovely and it's like they and then i
wake up and like it's confusing because
it takes a minute to
it's so big well yeah it's very vivid
like my mother
i'll have dreams of her and i'll wake up
and of my brother
vivid and they're just right there and
then
i remember oh they're not here but it
felt so real
like they were that's the difference
between a dream and a visitation
so
so how could can you connect with um a
necklace or
i i
typically spirit doesn't show me
business but they had me right lock it
and then they had me write a heart and
then a necklace
so i don't know if they're just but it's
fake oh jeez that goes right they had me
draw this heart so i don't know if you
connect with hearts or if there's a
piece of it's a piece of jewelry of your
mom's or something that you have
yes
i um i do have a locket that was given
to me a necklace that has a picture of
my mother
and myself in it perfect
and and i keep it in a box oh how sweet
but i love how she had me write this can
you see that
yes
yes yeah
hearts yeah and everything is with
hearts
i love it whose birthday is now your mom
uh someone just profile with primary
color balloons so if it's not today or
the week of my now uh becomes this three
month period so
i feel of course someone will have
something in a three-month period so it
has to be then more than one thing in in
this three-month period so
what freaking month are we in now
we're imagining about what day april may
june it would have to be birthdays
april okay end of april my brother's
birthday april 30th and what's coming up
also or an anniversary
it could be an anniversary of a death
the end of july
my brother had his his accident
and so those fall around the same time
the beginning of august my mother and my
brother years apart but
it's always uh that time of year can you
connect with the number 12
i don't like to waste time on numbers
because i'm the first one to say i
misinterpreted something i don't
understand something when it comes to
numbers um it could be the 12th of a
month
it could be the month of january the
month of february i don't care how you
could connect with it um or an age like
oh when i was 12
i i think that's the age difference and
that's the thing that comes to mind okay
between you and your brother yes i i
don't know what it is with your brother
i feel
and i always say this is why i'm good at
what i do because i always say things
even though i don't even like i have
like almost 20 years of signs and
symbols
tucked away in my hair not only kidding
how does that feel
so when spirit makes me feel like i
could feel something but i can't grasp
it
it mean it's like either
there's like this if that's the way that
they were they weren't so forthcoming
with certain things or like emotions or
or just
or like this
fear and it's just like
i just i keep feeling like i just keep
hearing him say it was a freak thing
that happened the day that i died and no
disrespect to your brother's departure
do you understand that sure yes it was
like how could this hap you know like
this is crazy it's like
hypothetically like if i drove this road
every day like how did i crash at that
turn i know this turn i know this road
yes
exactly it was on turn and on a road
that
we all knew for really so many years so
and the race motorcycle was very very
good and precision and
he was very good at what he did yeah
and so for something like that and he
drove so much so well i just want to say
truth several things to you how he also
got me to say this was he showed me when
spirit shows me a pothole and a squirrel
in it it's my symbol for that i know so
weird so random
i love squirrels
girls yeah i channeled we've been seeing
a lot of squirrels lately i channeled
the squirrel once before by the way oh
my god
somebody had a squirrel as a pet it was
the most craziest thing oh um
but so when they show me that it's my
symbol for where we had to maneuver a
vehicle or something in a manner and
then when they show me sand it's a
wipeout it just means that there was
like this again a
freak thing that happened
and i'm gonna say this that there's like
this thing like i feel like he's
defending his driving he's like i wasn't
even driving crazy that day he's like
wow i've driven crazier tourists he's
like you have no idea he's like i was
like evil knievel in my day
oh my gosh evil knievel
they used to have my brothers had these
evil knievel outfits growing up and it
was like a running joke in the family
many years ago i spoke
to
a medium and the same
sentiment came up she didn't know and
she had said that similar thing
negotiating the curve i i can't believe
like he was disappointed in himself
the fact that he that was not well i i
didn't feel the disappointment you know
uh
a lot of times when people say this to
me they'll say oh i've i've heard this
before when spirit repeats things
through a medium whether it's the same
medium or a different medium it means
it's something that we really we had to
hear again and maybe this is to clarify
like if you remember what your brother
said he was taking responsibility for
that day
you understand that and it wasn't and it
was like it was so crazy teresa i've
i've traveled this road i've driven
crazier before my life like how the heck
did this happen
you know and not wanting us to carry
this burden our guilt
do you still have his license or
something about his wallet and then he
wanted to talk about his jeans for some
reason
something dennis um
i used to make fun of his jeans perfect
because
because he was a night owl and he would
just be going out as i was going to bed
and he would ask me if his outfit looked
okay and i always told him he dressed
like 80s i was like you gotta like
change your jeans perfect this completed
thing's not working
welcome back cotter the cute thing about
the jeans is because
i kind of
didn't understand something or he was
trying to maybe get me to say something
that i wasn't familiar with so i just
wanted him to validate that maybe he was
making fun of your genie maybe he was
oh that was so sweet he just said he
goes i could never make fun of her she
was always so cute
that sounds like something he would say
like he just made me feel like he just
gave my my heart this hug
do you remember years ago when you would
go to like your grandparents house and
they would have like your name like
etched in the door jam or like your
height when spirit shows me that and
then they show me a tree
that's my symbol for where we
either wrote something or had something
carved in memory of them
i don't care if you put it in cement or
if it actually wasn't a piece of wood or
if you did like do a tree or a bench in
memory of him
oh
um in memory of him um but he keeps
writing a name and i don't know what it
is or carved and then he keeps showing
me the cement
oh wow um
where he died this is um no no i feel
like it's somewhere like a vacation hat
or like a house i
we did have a lot of um
the house we grew up in the basement
which is appropriate my mother put our
art on the basement walls so she didn't
have to show there was so much of it but
there was a lot of drawings and a lot of
uh
height maps and
my brothers were both right on those
and he did
and something that comes to mind is
he used to give me monkeys every year
for my birthday bags
and at christmas he would always
he would come to visit me in college and
he would bring
monkeys because he knew i liked them
and
he had a
it was the initial m
and i would put on my desk and i had a
little monkey on it so it was my initial
it was a little
so i've had that for several years and
that's what i can think about um
it's your connection so whatever you i'm
i'm not going to get that so he i kept
seeing that remember that but i didn't
see the inside of it remember um
the plastic monkeys that you would get
you guys are too young for this probably
yeah the real the the barrel the barrel
yeah they would hang from each other he
gave me this oh he gave me this one year
i didn't know what that was i didn't
know what that was
he gave me those oh that's so funny i
forgot about that i had so many monkeys
i started giving them away to my friends
kids as i got older i was like what am i
going to do with these um do you do you
still have the box of his belongings
um he just brought me to a cardboard box
so that's my symbol for where someone
has someone's belongings but then i saw
like generations of things yeah you do
right from florida that you got from
florida i do i have um his things here
and i i my other brother has i believe a
lot of his belongings
was there a child named after him or a
form of a name
or who was named after someone
uh he was named after my father okay
he just kept showing me the namesake and
when they say john john to me that's my
symbol for that someone was named after
someone oh yeah he was named after my
father so
was frank was my father francis but your
dad is departed as well
yes he's very quiet
he's very he was very he was like
he looks at me and he goes i don't know
about you theresa
that makes sense
he was skeptical he was quiet very quiet
very very quiet but like very supportive
like i
he just stands there you know and just
very supportive
um
did you just come across the picture of
you standing in front of the house the
family home or was there
usually when spirit shows me a house and
we have a porch and then i see like
people standing in front it's just my
symbol for that we were just going
through old photos and as i said
yeah and there's this one special photo
because he turned the photo to black and
white and then burnt the edges around it
that's my civil for where there's one
special photo that you always always
look at
yes
that's funny i was just looking at
photos and i found one
where families together on the porch at
our house
it was a rare
photo because it was hard to get all of
us in one place
so that's a special photo perfect so
know that when you found that photo when
every time you look at that photo know
that the souls of your loved ones are
with you at that exact moment
that's really nice
i'm gonna cry
i'm gonna cry
i can't believe you haven't cried yet
yeah you're right he's going nuts
i knew that you were gonna be like this
life could be a dream sweetheart
hello hello again
[Music]
theresa is it ever like
specific specific like
i'm seeing a joe montana rookie card
that's kind of frayed on the edges you
know like something like that
i've only gotten that with a pokemon
card no oh okay
[Laughter]
it all depends everyone is different
everyone's messages are different it
depends on what people can handle what
they can handle
because there's this even though you've
lost so much maggie there's this sense
of i feel that
you have found some sort of peace or
that there's some type of you know what
whether if this is what you believe the
validations it's just like you know that
they're okay
i think after that tragedy you have to
either
you'll buckle if you don't find the
okay just it gives you a different
perspective of life and a different
appreciation
and it allows you to
let things that may bother other people
things that are insignificant it allows
you to see things differently i think at
least for me yeah and and not everyone
feels that way
not everyone gets to that point look
there are some times i can say to
someone did you just lose your loved one
because i feel like it just happened
yesterday and they're like no this
happened 20 years ago they're holding it
they're holding on and it's so raw as if
it just happened yesterday i couldn't do
that i think that's too
fragile of a state yeah for me where
i wouldn't be able to live like that so
i've had to sort of
you know not saying i'm at a point where
it's easy because it'll never be easy
but i'm sure you've seen
a lot of that i've seen and felt so much
the way that people pass and there was
something that i admire about you you're
this young beautiful woman and you've
lost so much and to have this
mindset well i could feel that from your
soul on how you are this is
the moment that i love right now is that
because this is why i do what i do that
hopefully people that do lose a loved
one
that they can get to that place where
you're at i appreciate that yeah because
it's not something that i i don't say
that to people you know usually they're
so fragile and i i can feel that but
your brother kept playing music uh yeah
so you have to be able to connect with
music i don't know what the yes what is
if it's rock bands rod stewart whatever
it is but he's like playing all this
music and it's like such a different
collection yes oh he always had um it
was funny because he
he liked so many different types of
music he never was like specifically on
one type and he his collection was
so
like it was like strange i'm like what
yeah eclectic yeah so that explains the
broad stewart the grateful dead
yeah all of oh yeah
yeah when was it that he that he died uh
2002 2003 but he grew up he was in the
80s 70s 80s best years ever
oh one other thing maggie did you change
um
a piece of your mom's jewelry i have her
um engagement ring she left that to me
okay
only because when spirit shows me an
engagement ring into a necklace it's
just my symbol that we're thinking about
changing a piece of jewelry yeah that
this does not mean you run to the
jeweler tomorrow and you change no no
it's just validating that
a her soul was with you at that exact
moment
also
validating if you do choose to change it
she supports that choice and decision
wow that's good do you know did somebody
lose a child does somebody have a
miscarriage or a termination um my
mother
she actually had
she had miscarriages but she lost twins
they were born she had me right child
first she had me write child child
miscarriage oh my god you just
discovered this recently right well no i
knew um since i was younger she the
first two that she had were twins
peter and paul and they were her first
children and with my dad and and they
died after nine hours after they were
born good and that was they were on a
naval base because my father was um in
the navy
flying and uh
so
they told her it was risky because she
was so petite and it was back in the 60s
like early 60s and um
and yeah they they passed so she lost
three kids so she yeah
um so if you look at my paper
once again
oh my gosh wow yes wow what's 32 yeah i
see a number 32 right now i don't know
the age i wish i want to be justin
i was
like weirdly it's also o.j simpson's
number
so all right so well that's interesting
because see when i doodle and i write um
it's for a reason um so 32 could be an
age um it could stand for the month of
march and the month of february it could
stand for a year
1932. hmm
interesting
but
well that's so that's so yeah so that
it's interesting people sometimes like
to see my pick because i write i do i
write things and i'm like oh cause
here's my little monkeys things that i
that it would be like what is that oh my
god
but it's interesting when you're in
front of me and people are like what are
you writing over there
and i drew several penises
i was gonna say don't worry they're not
the lottery numbers
you're just scribbling genitalia
um
uh that is so really cool to see thanks
for listening thank you yeah that's
awesome well well i want to thank you
for uh trusting me uh with the souls of
your departed loved ones and for giving
me that privilege of being able to to
channel them for you this afternoon
thank you so much really
i feel very privileged to have chatted
with you and get that insight it's so
nice it's always like it's very
comforting right and you provide
a comfort to say okay it's okay
everything is yeah everyone is still
there with you and i feel that yeah
and you're very warm so thank you that's
awesome thanks for letting me witness it
i feel like yeah
are you okay do you need tissue no i'll
be okay i'm just waiting to see i'm just
waiting to see if you put that earbud
directly back in your ear no i'll do
that yeah no i just cleaned my hair oh
that's fine yeah i'm not sure i'm scared
mine i wouldn't trust as much
thanks man bye maggie nice to meet you
that was more emotional for you it was
thank
um okay what is your most commonly used
emoji would you say when you text
oh it's it's always the heart or kissy
face
oh yeah yeah i like those two yeah i was
gonna say the poop emoji but
well you can this is a safe space
we've said some other crazy [ __ ] during
this conversation
um i thought maybe the little uh if you
could be a professional athlete what
sport would you play and why theresa uh
football
football yeah who's uh the jets no
no no i am a cowboy fan you know why
because i always i thought i was going
to be a dallas cowgirl cheerleader
so did i yeah
yeah what could have been uh i should
have won so you yeah but they also had
some great teams probably when you were
growing up that was probably yours yeah
i i've always loved the cowboys and i
recently went to the football hall of
fame and i learned something i didn't
realize how much the cowboys and the
packers like [ __ ] nfl like oh yeah oh my
god it was so interesting
yeah tom landry and all those there's
some really great um teams back then and
then they went through this off this
period in the 80s where they sucked and
then they yeah we got troy aikman and
emmitt smith again and they built up the
team they were great again in the 90s
you know what's been fun i've been
watching a lot of old um old football
games like games from like 1996 you know
and it's so fun i forget who won or lost
it's still exciting uh
it's been a real treat um if you could
have one snack food for the rest of your
life what would that be
oh uh reese's peanut butter cups
oh yeah they're great have you had the
me the thin ones that oh yeah they're
thin ones that i sort of prefer because
it's not as much chocolate it's a little
bit more of a peanut butter the
chocolate ratio um what's your favorite
movie of all time oh sixth sense
uh oh yeah
and just because you related so much and
pretty woman
yeah
uh you probably already knew this but i
i've yet to see
pretty woman in its entirety i know
it's funny that this is the most you
just
did you just hear that that was my heart
shattering
yeah that's
the spirit of gary marshall oh god
okay something about julia roberts and
richard gere is just ah
it's crazy so she's a prostitute right
and he is like he hires her
i know it's crazy it's crazy to me that
this is such a beloved movie um because
i only know the idea about it
i just love oh it's just it's great it's
it's fantastic it's a classic no i'm
ashamed
i know i know i should see it um if you
had to live somewhere else besides
hicksville where would it be uh arizona
oh yeah really why i love arizona i just
and it's not sedona it's not the it's
just i
i travel all over and i feel so
comfortable there you know i just love
arizona and i love middle america i you
know me too me too i i do too there's a
great
if you when you do go back to arizona uh
tucson i love there's a section of
tucson this is so like old-fashioned
it's where they and there's a great
hotel you know oh this mission is in is
in tucson
oh yes i think that sounds like i went
there it's familiar really
and
in a place like that with that kind of
rich history yeah i mean i know i've
already asked you this but do you feel
anything there i feel everything all the
time you know
it's just my world you know yeah yeah
there's a next time you go there's a
great place called i think it's called
the hotel
congress the congress hotel this
i'll remember the name of it
congresswoman it's where they cornered
john dillinger and they smoked him out
no and and in that fire a couple kids
died incredible ghost stories there and
people have felt things and there's some
amazing uh
uh
stories about people seeing things and
smelling things and really cool um
if you
uh could have dinner with three people
dead or alive whom you've never met uh
or in your case whom you've met
uh
who would it who would they be oh i'd
have to say
blake shelton
okay
gwen stefani i love them i i met them i
went to the voice a couple of times oh
yeah yeah i just i'm just huge huge fans
um okay you you're fans of theirs as a
couple or they're musicians you're the
music both
yeah yeah every way shape or form i just
i just love
i don't know i just i i just love them
i just think they're adorable and i just
i admire her and
did they want you to do a reading for
them no
no no no they were just like cool you
like us yeah
yeah uh who else would i want to have
dinner with i i don't know i'm not um
i'd love to have dinner with you but
yeah okay
but uh it was
i'm in i i i'm into it um
who's your favorite muppet if you were a
fan of them i would have to be miss
piggy
yeah sure of course yeah that was a
trick
if if you could have one superpower
besides the one you already have
what would it be
i don't we ever like oh god i want to be
able to
fly or somebody said someone recently
that i loved was like i want to speak
every language in the world
i don't know i my mind went totally
somewhere else like i went i wanted to
be like bewitch where i could just
twitch my nose and my house would be
clean
oh great that counts yeah i like that
that's good i wouldn't mind that i'm
very simple justin
no i think that's that's what makes what
you do and the way you do it so
compelling is because
there's something so accessible about it
just just witnessing what you did with
maggie it wasn't like
i'm getting this sentence you didn't go
into theatrics it was just like hey look
this is what i'm picking up um
really cool if you could be reincarnated
i know you don't believe in that
necessarily but as a non-human animal oh
you do yeah as a as an animal or if you
if you wanted to exhibit your spirit to
a loved one what form would you think
you would take
i don't i when you were talking i saw an
owl
oh
oh i'm really into owls funny we have a
lot of owls around here yeah an owl
mm-hmm
they seem wise they seem like they carry
a lot of uh important you know like
knowledge maybe that's just from the
cartoon or or just maybe the fact that
they could spin their head completely
around that's pretty cool yeah that's
cool because that's what i think people
think is going to happen to me once i
start channeling
right right they're amazed when you
don't levitate and start throwing up
um would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny
oh god
i know both would suck both would be i i
would stay more
unattractive because you know yeah me
too yeah yeah
i don't think it cares what someone
looks like it's you know who they are
inside so right especially when you have
such a good understanding of
the after like the non-physical world
it's like okay look yeah this is not
gonna last you know
uh which golden speaking of which golden
girl do you most identify with dorothy
blanche rose or sophia
oh i was gonna say blanche but i love
the mother sophia
yeah you've got a bit of a sofia sound i
will say uh that's fine how old are you
kids now uh 29 and 25.
oh wow oh wow
and do you are they do they have any of
your gifts so
that's a little hard because i believe
everyone has a gift my son is extremely
intuitive uh very sensitive my daughter
seems to possess a little bit more of
myself
um you know where she
takes on other people's emotions and
energies and things like that so hmm
okay uh and and uh the beatles are the
rolling stones oh god i'm gonna have to
say the rolling stones knowing stones i
knew you're
dogs or cats dogs
okay unless if it's a tiger
you have a dog uh i had three three but
now they're like kind of like living
other places because i was traveling so
much so oh
on tour are you on yeah so it was it was
unfair to them you know so
my son took bubba victoria's fiancee
took bentley and uh my friend victoria
woods took louie
yeah nice okay victoria what's the one
you work with yeah oh okay cool um
if you could only eat meatloaf the food
or listen to meatloaf the singer for the
rest of your life you can only choose
one
which means every time you hear a
meatloaf song
you have to leave the room or whatever
but or or you could enjoy meatloaf the
food ah
what do you pick i'm gonna have to i'm
gonna say the song
oh wow okay yeah all right that's a
lovely old classic come on oh i love
sure hey if it comes back to new york
teresa you gotta see i i don't know if
it's come there yet uh bad out of hell i
didn't see it and i'm a huge broadway
person i love broadway
i saw it in london it was in london when
i was working there i saw it twice
you're gonna love it um i i can't thank
you enough this was such a such a
fascinating
conversation to have thank you i
appreciate it very much
[Music]
spooky yeah spooky i thought you could
do a long island accent long oh yes well
that happened well that happened
yeah she was a very thick accent it's a
very distinctive very distinctive
hicksville long island and i'm so
curious because i found myself so taken
by her first of all i was just so
charming i sounded taken by her yeah you
said a number of times you know you just
seem like such a rational
down-to-earth person well like you're
not performing at all it's true she
wasn't doing like odamae brown stuff
which i kind of expected maybe that's
why i felt that way i was so strongly
maybe that's why you went into my
thinking
yeah she was gonna be like okay i'm
picking up some vibrations you know
like she was
some character in a movie
i guess it was odama brown but also
anytime i've seen a medium um or
patricia arquette in medium
yeah but i think she's more normal she's
very flat i mean as patricia arquette
tends to be you know that that kind of
like yes dry delivery try i would say
flat would suggest that she's not
animated or but she is kind
of a cat
yes she's not very animated she can be
and should her perform i just have you
seen that show no
you've seen mediums can i have for the
last 30 seconds of my life
she was a very disarmingly normal
yeah she was just like regular person
well the most compelling uh examples of
people that i would consider to be have
those abilities psychic medium abilities
whatever um have always come in the form
of somebody very blase about it do you
know what i mean like i'm thinking about
my former the guy the hair stylist on ed
the tv show and nathan bush who i've
talked about who was the best um but
nathan
claimed that he had a very
strong spiritual side and he claimed he
was really into what's that brazilian
spirituality
i forget but he had a very strong
connection to the afterlife and he would
say very matter-of-factly
uh oh yes i see dead people sometimes
yeah i i see them yep i said well like
do you ever see any we were in the
makeup trailer do you ever see any in
here oh sometimes i'll let you know see
i think that it makes sense that if you
are someone who has been seeing dead
people all the time for your entire life
at a certain point you're going to
become desensitized you're not going to
be like
yeah yeah that's true and she was when
you asked about the skeptics and how she
treats that you know yeah that pushback
she
um gave a very kind of matter of fact
like i don't give a [ __ ] if you don't
believe me kind of answer she was like
you know believe me or not i'm not my my
job is to try to convince you she's
that's what i'm saying she didn't seem
concerned at all so wasn't that
compelling to you i mean it was i'm not
look yeah i can tell that you're a bit
you don't you're not well of course i'm
a bit skeptical come on i'm a [ __ ] if
you're not a bit skeptical then
she would be written up in science
journals and she would like i know but
there's no way to prove that stuff
scientifically uh of course not but it's
i think
i would guess the scientific community
at large does not
believe that what she is saying is
really possible so what do you say what
do you attribute it to i mean let's say
it's not let's say
haven't you talked to people who were
like oh yeah i friends of yours who were
like i saw a ghost i'm not saying i
don't believe or i or i do believe her
here's what i'm saying i i think i went
into this thinking about mediums that
they had to fall
into into one of three categories either
they were
goldberg they were either complete con
artists and they're making the whole
thing up
or they were
psychotic and they were seeing visions
that just weren't there and they had
something wrong with them yeah but they
really believed that what they were
seeing was you know legit
or three they're totally right and and
what they're saying is completely 100
true and i always thought it kind of had
to be one of those three things
but after
listening to that the reading that she
did on maggie i i
found myself
falling a little bit in the middle
somewhere in the middle of it because i
don't think it necessarily has to be so
black or white you know i don't think
you have to be either psychotic and
seeing visions or completely
legitimately i think there's maybe some
embellishment going on i think there's
it comes from a real feeling i think
there may be some truth to it i just
think it's a like a a mix it's like a
stew of it's it's a bunch of ingredients
coming together i know what you mean i
don't think she's totally making it up i
don't think she's i know what you mean
completely full of [ __ ] i don't believe
that that maybe she picks up on certain
things certain energies but
you know and i felt this way i don't
wanna spoiler alert we have another
medium coming on uh but i felt this way
with him too which was that there was a
way to
i think some people are more obviously
more empathetic than others and she
may be so empathetic so sensitive to
other people's
vibrations and and traumas and whatever
that maybe she picks up on certain
things
psychologically um
and i just want to give a little bit
more context about maggie before she
gets in because i can't say this in
front of her because it'd be too
embarrassing but uh maggie for all the
you know i know that she's here in this
very specific for this very specific
reason but um
people should know that she's just an
incredibly positive buoyant person
despite
all of the the tragedy that she's dealt
with in her life so and i'm sure you can
hear that but
she's not somebody who seems to dwell i
really admire her for that she doesn't
seem to really dwell on these tragedies
and i know you do too you it's probably
hard for you to say because it's your
girlfriend and
uh
it's personal so i i just feel like
people should know that before she comes
in all right let's get her in okay
and here she is
maggie
margaret
pretty cool
yeah
um we want to hear what your impressions
were of the reading
so that happened well we already did
that for our hungry
i was dying to do that
well i have to say i'm very open to
these kind of things because one of my
aunts is as i've mentioned before um
sees
so for since i was very little
she would
you know talk to us about that stuff and
she's been written up and
you know
she's worked with um police stations and
uh investigative
uh like detectives and whatnot her
name's jean brown
so you had some experience with this
going into it so theresa
you i was downstairs during this and you
guys were up here and at the end of the
interview having not seen it uh was you
came down you seemed like very blase
about how it went you're like yeah it
was interesting it was she was really
nice and and justin came down kind of
weepy-eyed and he seemed like he had
seen a ghost himself
so i'm wondering
if your
immediate post
reading experiences have changed hearing
it back
or thinking about it more yes
and i mean one could say oh you can you
can find anything out of that but i
think it is
true that after listening to it back
um and seeing it i
more personal things came up it's like
oh that's what she was sort of veering
towards and i just didn't pick it up at
the time like she kept talking about
jewelry and
my mother's ring and certain things that
i just didn't get and the name the
namesake my even my my other brother my
nephew and
little things came up and
and i've heard that before oh
this might not make sense now but
um later on and and she even said like
this doesn't make sense to me
um but it has some significance to you
were you nervous going into it i kind of
was because you never know if you're
gonna like
oh my god am i gonna have a meltdown and
like cry and like traumatic fear about
mediums and getting readings and stuff
is that well like you were saying your
aunt would do i would be afraid that i
was gonna hear something
tragic some something like prophetic
that was like
you know in a couple days uh you'll be
walking along the road and but i don't
think i think there's a difference
between a medium and uh clairvoyant
right like mediums don't tell you what's
going to happen in the future do they
mediums are more uh
the other side yeah people have passed
and
see and you asked her about that john at
one point you said um do you ever hear
from
uh spirits who are angry or disgruntled
in some way and
and she didn't seem
to have any experiences with that um she
said there was one one or two
yeah um i know like my aunt would say
um
that things would come to her but she
didn't want to tell people so she um
like if it was really bad it's something
that they didn't want to hear she would
kind of shield them
um if it was something that she didn't
think they'd be able to handle because
you can't like outright say
yes see yeah
i was clairvoyant i was i was trying to
put myself in your shoes when i was
listening back as much as i can put
myself in your shoes but i was imagining
hearing all this information
from a stranger about personal things
about
my dead loved ones
and i was imagining
the skeptical part of me the part of me
that didn't really believe that
she has these powers i was imagining
myself getting really angry
with her even speculating about
communicating with my loved ones
it seemed like because by the way if if
she is making it up i'm not saying she
is if she is that's extraordinarily
disrespectful yeah sure yeah
and she probably struggles i would
imagine
having that gift
if we're saying okay that is true she
has this gift that's got to be something
that
she struggles with or anyone would
struggle with because like you're
telling somebody something
um
and you have to
and usually the people that you're she's
talking to would hopefully have an open
mind otherwise they wouldn't be sitting
down with her it's true but it's still a
lot of responsibility right it is it
sure is
what what like really struck you like uh
detail-wise detail like holy [ __ ] it was
weird she said um the accident
um on the road she said that the curve
and that's something she wouldn't have
known that's not something in the papers
or anything like that that was never
documented where she would find that
and um
and i didn't i i was thinking and i
think i may have asked you did she even
ask like she knew that tragic accident
she said um
like she was pointing to her chest like
um blood but she there was no time when
i said
car accident i didn't i don't did i say
that i don't think i did
you may have
i don't think so but
i think
she captured like
she said things that were very much like
things that my brother damien would say
like
um
just
she kind of captured his uh like spirit
and
his musical taste and and that's the
second person i spoke with another
medium and she said the same thing about
music and uh
the road and
this is very similar really like
so it's almost like he's trying to
communicate that yeah and he's like it
was like stupid it was like dumb luck i
remember when you first told me about
that story that was what you said about
it you said
he
was on this road that he had been on a
million times before and he knew it so
well and it was and that's why i also
when she said your brother
feels
responsible for the accident you know it
was his fault like he shouldn't he knew
better like he knew that road yeah
and that i thought was really
interesting it compared to your father's
accident which was like
you know not
close to
nothing close to being his fault you
know yeah
i thought that was interesting in the
the monkey when we were talking about
the monkeys and she said the barrel of
monkeys yeah
and uh
there's actually something that he he
gave me
they're probably around the same age too
so
he probably grew up around that time
period when those were she actually knew
him really well but i mean not to pick i
don't want to pick apart um
everything that she said but it felt
real it felt genuine i have been to
people where i know they're like these
little pop-up shops where they're like
let me tell you yeah you went to the
long beach medium yes
the coney island media
she was not that she's you could tell
she's an empath
um you could tell she she's an empath
truly and
because christian i mean that's the
thing with not when you don't see it
it's hard to even when she was her chest
she was feeling heavy in the chest like
unless she's just in a she's meryl
streep
it seemed very genuine it seemed like a
really good i have to watch the video
because there is a video that
accompanied it but i wanted to first
just listen to it because i wanted to
you know
be in the shoes of other people
listening to this podcast and i wanted
that to be the takeaway but
now i'm going to watch the video um
she
you should i it's
at one point she interrupts we're
talking to her response very quickly oh
he said this
and it was
just
like she like cut us off to say oh he
says this and it was
something he would say about the
oh i would never do that to her she's he
was very
um
you know sometimes you're with siblings
you're
he's just very kind and uh very
protective of me and just
sweet just so sweet um so you know it
was a nice like testament to
um to him that's not right the right
word but um tribute it was a nice
tribute yeah so at the very least even
if
well at the very least that's such a
nice thing to have
yeah and i um
that salute so toward the end after i
left the salute
from someone in the service she said do
you remember that yeah i didn't know
what she was talking about so i was
thinking that could definitely
to me that stood out as like my father
being a pilot and serving the country
and he was a pilot in vietnam right yes
and he um
i could see that very much being from
him because
um
justin i mean just the way she was
talking to you about it uh you're
you're compassionate and such a kind
man always starting to cry
and you're such a generous loving man
and
when she's talking about this i'm
involving you and saluting you i i know
that my
father would be extremely
happy that i'm surrounding myself with
two very
stand up good truly good men
and
and i thought you know that that's gotta
be him i mean
he
he would be very happy and he'd be very
pleased
he'd say thanks for putting up with her
oh that's such a pleasure i wish i knew
how to salute him back
that's how that's how we're probably
very different in that regard
we were boy scouts that's something
you do know the boy scout salute
and i know him and my brother and my
mother would be very very pleased with
the two of you oh very um that's so nice
not to like
throw on the compliments but truly
you're very well raised and
just good men really truly and do you
think they would like the podcast i
think that my mother would say well
they're swearing a lot
[Laughter]
she would be appalled
your mother's i mean she sounds a lot
like our mother she she does yeah
very very similar well i'm glad you got
to have that experience
yeah i did i i'm glad i did too and
thank you guys thanks margaret thank you
thanks teresa
um
while i have the microphone oh
yeah
can we talk about what christian's
wearing right now
let me describe it
yeah how would you describe it um
is a white headband
that's the only thing that's out of the
ordinary
he's wearing regular gray shorts no
white with
ears
little cat ears that are pink on the
inside
didn't you give him that headband i did
to help when i put a mask on him once
you know because this summer
all right
excellent
it's good that you got that in there and
what other embarrassing tidbits you know
the summer time is not the greatest for
christian because he has you both have
this beautiful sicilian
skin thank you um but
sometimes it's more on the oily side so
in the summer
he's standing behind me and well thanks
for coming what types of things does he
enjoy uh behind closed doors
so thanks for coming that's puzzles in
the morning everybody's a creature of
habit thanks for coming
he does like a puzzle
oh thanks margaret
nice to be able to witness that uh
that reading yeah now i feel bad about
saying that maybe it wasn't true well i
mean you know what [ __ ] it it was true
well i do know this i know that it was a
very meaningful experience and
it affected somebody that we both care
about uh you know in a very positive way
and that's the most important thing yeah
um so so thank you theresa thank you for
that yeah and one one final thing a
little bit off topic her uh
this is a woman who can communicate
actively
with dead people
she doesn't know all the time yeah
wherever she is
but yet
if given an opportunity to have dinner
with
three people that she's never met
blake shelton and gwen stefani
and you
i mean nothing against blake shelton and
gwen stefani they're talented and
they're good musicians but
really
of all the people i forgot about that
maybe that maybe that's actually
too
too that that like speaks to the truth
of what she said yeah because she's sick
she can see
anybody yeah i'm lincoln
all these like famous dead people and
she's like ah i'm sick of them yeah give
me like a fun pop star oh i did
mongolian barbecue with genghis khan
last week
um let's read a letter okay
uh it's this one this is a letter from
kate can you want me to turn the light
on uh no that's right
do i look like i'm squinting yeah you
i did an old man like you push it away
from my face five feet away from your
face like i had bifocals um this is from
kate
subject well
that happened dear justin and christian
my name is kate h i like that she
knows she knows
she's heard a letter or two yeah on the
show uh and i am from york
in the uk that's up north i think right
in york
i'm not going to try it aren't you proud
of me in the uk yeah yeah i just wanted
to reach out because i love the podcast
i thought you just said you weren't i
know but then i
got i got the better you got the itch
i'm a key i'm a key worker healthcare
support for individuals with mental
health issues and learning disabilities
although i'm not on the front line i am
i am unable to stay home during this
pandemic i also work nights and you guys
get me through my darkest hours
literally now thanks kate it really
cheered me up that episode where justin
kept singing green day i was due to go
see them play live but it's canceled due
to covid your version was well timed
and i swear to god i thought billy joe
was with you what with laughter emoji oh
okay yeah
i got excited until i saw the emoji
uh we are living through unprecedented
times and your quarantine episodes are
just great so empathetic and informative
i'm sorry empathic she said it properly
empathic and informative doctor dave is
a hero oh
yeah we got to do another quarantine
episode and jerry well
who doesn't adore that guy you hear that
jerry
i laughed so hard when you hung up on
him
then he called back um
that's funny life is short it's such a
wonderful phrase an idea to keep in mind
so we don't end up sweating the small
stuff and waste energy and time worrying
about things that may never come to be i
agree kate i just wish i followed that
advice more
i would like to mention that you speak
about mental health in one form or
another every podcast and it's so
heartening to hear almost all your
guests sharing experiences we truly are
all in this [ __ ] together and we should
be excellent to each other i love that
line we should be excellent to each
other covet or no covet
excited for the new bill and ted i was
just thinking that yeah
i i wanted to join in the would you
rather bandwagon but it's not my strong
suit i'll try anyway that's okay kate
would you rather have to dress in full
drag for the rest of your life or a
cumbersome dinosaur outfit the ones with
metal framing inside that sits on your
shoulders to support the dinosaur head
whoa
drag it's easy easy easy um even if it's
like crazy stiletto heels
i think it would have to be i i don't
think you get away with just like a wig
and a little bit of rouge
and like a crop top i think you got to
go all out like
style i think what it comes down to is
i'd rather be a woman than a dinosaur
yeah but i think it's just that simple
of course and it's more acceptable
socially i mean here's here's what i
think it should be just it sounds so
uncomfortable to wear the big head
exactly yeah i think the drag outfit has
to full drag has to be um
like fish nets it has to impress neil
patrick harris that's gonna be the most
it has to be like hedwig yes hedwig drag
yeah it's gonna be like he's gonna be
like damn uh that's a lot it's a lot and
it'd be a lot to do every day heavy
makeup heavy makeup uh
wearing heels is hard you've never tried
it i have it's very difficult uh i still
would do the full drag i wouldn't want
that big dinosaur head on me yeah
and then you're like the dinosaur guy
yeah instead of just like a fierce
fabulous you're not living as a human
really you're living as a dinosaur
exactly this way and you know let's face
it it's
it can be cool i thought you would say
let's face it i'm not that far off from
doing that yeah anyway even though
you're wearing it as maggie pointed out
a uh little kitten headband
you're you have a good start okay well i
just want to for the record say that i'm
wearing this because i want to keep my
hair out of my forehead
yes and then kate goes on to say uh
local business shout out oh good cake
girl in york
cake girl one word gorgeous homemade
doesn't cake sounds so good right
cupcakes oh cake sounds great but a
cupcake
[ __ ] i have an addict what's your
favorite cupcake combination uh
chocolate chocolate based chocolate top
vanilla based chocolate i think you know
this mine is vanilla based chocolate top
and mine too you know
[Laughter]
so anyway that's cake girl in york if
you're looking for a good cupcake uh
they're so delicious and don't care that
you end up with all of it over your face
she says you wish you could spread it
all over your body whoa jesus
uh and this took a turn
oh wow
all the best uh cupcake
as she will now be known on the show all
the best and please stay silly
heart emoji ah kate thanks kate uh
you too stay silly even though you are
not we're not in a silly time
and what she's doing sounds really
intense well thank you and and we're so
glad we could keep you feeling a little
silly okay okay thank you to teresa
caputo and thank you to margaret
for uh being such a good sport
and uh if you guys want to write in
write us a letter our email address is
maggie life is short at
wondery.com and thanks everyone for
listening thanks to maggie thanks to
teresa thanks to kate and everyone who's
listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it's co-hosted and produced by you
christian long it's also produced by
megan monaco senior producer is michelle
miesh lans an audio engineer is sergio
enrique
executive producers are marshall
louie
and hernan lopez for who wondering hey
all right
[Music]
excited for your big debut tomorrow
um
i don't know i haven't really had much
time to think about to be honest
can you take a picture of me on my
on my oh look this is a good prop right
before i get on this call in one minute
oh wait let me put a pencil on it
oh [ __ ]
tomorrow
was that my way of showing you that i
haven't let's chat about it i just can't
right now you just got recorded
you